[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back here
if it was Griffin and once again I'm
back into all things comedy studio I
told you I would be today's guest
a new good friend of mine actually the
legend himself give it up for mr. Pauly
Shore you gonna be a nightmare from the
jump
thank you come see your face how did you
come up with the name riffing with
Griffin they just rhyme you know
actually I was at a I was at a college
gig yeah I was at just college gig and I
was doing like an Instagram live thing
and I was like I'm about to do a podcast
and what do you guys think you know of a
name and I was coming up with all these
stupid names and then some girl was like
rhythm with Griffin and I was like - did
you give her credit
no I don't remember what her name is
what's her but where was this it was on
Instagram but where oh she just hit you
randomly yeah because I was doing I was
in the green room and I was doing an
Instagram live okay so I did the show
and then she was like a roofer with
Griffin so perfect yeah so you don't
know her name I don't know her you got
to give her a little cash yeah what you
doing to me right now
Bobbie Lee did Chinese dumpling yes
you're just so tell me I'm gonna be tame
for you cuz I know you think I'm not
gonna be tame no no I know I could be
crazy you have you you can be crazy when
you invited me to Gordon Ramsay yeah we
were Gordon Ramsay yeah together that
was a that was something else but but
you know what it is what it is yeah
you're famous for this for what for
being Pauly Shore correct so when you go
places
they're expecting that anybody gonna be
like they're gonna be mad if you're not
crazy right so a while ago is that
probably three years ago right at least
three years I hit you up and I'm like
hey come with me to Gordon Ramsay show
yeah that was I first of all out of the
blue right I don't know why you even
called why'd you even call me for that I
like you're funny okay well there you
know but I we we don't have that many
conversations at the time
well you still make me laugh that's good
to know so and then you you say come so
I go with you it's me you and Brian
Moses right we're sitting at this table
I've never been anything like that
before because I don't know people at
home I don't know if you guys even know
like it's a big dinner party or right
you know and then the Gordon Ramsay you
see yelling at the people the cameras
moving around and then you decide to
like pick up your plate and go over
Gordie Gordie
this isn't cooked right and it was a
whole thing yeah well it wasn't it
wasn't cooked right it was free food but
I mean his whole thing is to be like
really good on his food right that's
this thing his things like making sure
are you allowed to swear on this as his
his whole thing is like this is [ __ ]
awesome food and then when I tasted it
wasn't good so that's I was like yo this
food is [ __ ] up I know but he took it
great that's what I loved about him he
into it so thanks for having me thanks
yeah this is new for you yes before
before we started rolling you guys
you're talking to the producer about
setting it up at your house what episode
is this this is gonna be I don't know
yet this is gonna be end of early 30s oh
wow yeah Wow because I have already have
some in the bank so here I have to
figure out where I want to put yours
this is where your podcast takes a [ __ ]
Holly Shore comes on you're like [ __ ]
Hail Mary [ __ ] we were desperate we
gotta polish sure but you know what I
want to tell you like when uh they had
the tribute at The Comedy Store for your
mom you were exceptionally funny that
night mmm it was like you were is like
something came over you not that you're
not normally funny but just that night
you were like at your most comfortable I
didn't had seen you in a long time
hmm like what what what were you what
was going on for you like well I think
me unlike everyone else at the store
except for maybe Argus I've been there
longer than ever anyone yeah so I felt I
felt that night that
it's my family the only mean I felt like
everyone there was you know knew me
since I was a baby and like I could feel
like I felt like I was at home you know
you had Louie Anderson there Byron Allen
was there Jim Carrey was there everyone
was there so I felt like you know those
are the people that I have relationships
with ever since I was a little kid so I
felt like you know I mean all you guys
are new you're so new you know are you
guys are new like the store every seven
six seven eight years has this big kind
of just in life I think music you know
comedy it switches so like I've been
there for decades you know since the
beginning I'm 51 and the store opened in
72 so I've been there what almost I
don't know what I can't even [ __ ] do
the math but it's been a while yeah so
it's like you know it's an emotional
place for me you know what I mean and
like when I go on stage there normally
it's just you know I [ __ ] her it's weird
it's a weird for me it's a weird place
to perform why is that yeah well it's my
mom's Club it's got I got all the
history there so it's all that personal
[ __ ] you know ever since I was a kid and
then also you know I'm Pauly Shore the
famous comedian guy that is you know
tours America and sell shows out so it's
like a juxtaposition it's like I have
this kind of white America audience that
you know knows me from all my films you
know son-in-law and seeing all these
films and my MTV everything that I've
been doing for 20-something years and
then then there's the Moms Club it's
always been that way for me even when
you know I mean it's always that way
it's just you know it's like a weird
thing I'm like two people there but like
of the different errors that you saw
like if you had to rank them mmm what
would it be
well I think it I mean obviously number
one is probably always gonna be the
Richard Pryor or Jim Carrey when those
guys were right there but I think even
in the 70s I mean I was there for Redd
Foxx and like you know and like who else
that Lenny Schultz was there and
Pat McCormick and like you know the
natural gas there you know Dave Tyree
you know all these guys that are you
know older now really older now you know
from the 70s you know I think that time
was awesome you know just because it was
like so new and then Cheech and Chong
was there oh yeah you know what I mean
and it was just it's just you know it's
different but I mean it's great now too
you know so it's like it's uh you prefer
those arrows though do you think I
prefer those time it'll song you know
what I mean it's not just the comedy
store I think it's just you know I think
those arrows I'm just happy I was able
to kind of experience the 70s 80s and
90s yeah did you ever want to like
actually take over for your mom I always
thought that's what you were gonna do
that you were gonna sit in the back of
the oor on a Monday Monday nights and
pass people at the store is that
something that you wanted to do or why
didn't that happen um a lot of it is
it's kind of a weird kind of a weird
situation
um I have to say like you know you have
other family members you know you have
brothers and you know in this weird
history that I have with them and uh and
I'm not Mitzi shore you don't I mean and
I don't want to be Mitzi shore you know
I'd do it and I I'm a a natural you know
I I naturally develop comics you know
that tour with me I mean every comic on
the wall here pretty much is open for me
you know not everyone but I mean most
comics you know I mean Rob Bobby opened
me for a while I mean I just like to I
like to develop comedians I love it
you know wouldn't that have been the
natural position for you to be in in
your own way not to say that you were
gonna do it like your mom but like you
did was was there ever thought you'd be
like okay now I want to move the drip
like to have the poly era at The Comedy
Store yeah I think that is something
that will at some point naturally happen
you know but right now it's kind of not
happening you know but at some point
it's it just is it just too much to deal
with like yeah I know family is a
[ __ ] yeah okay he
always talk about like you know in the
movies they always depict family it's
like people do everything for family but
in real life it seems like family is
like what is like what it's the bane of
your existence sometimes yeah no yeah
it's it's difficult you know what I mean
because you know I mean do you have
brothers and sisters no I'm only child
but I have my cousins and stuff that
don't do anymore
yeah so that's kind of the situation
yeah I got yeah so it's like I met one
of your brothers your doctor evil
brother it always has a dog with him in
law yeah he always comes to my show in
La Jolla yes yes some hot babe with him
yeah he's uh Scott's a funny guy Scott
he uses that dog as a prop for sure to
get a [ __ ] I mean like without that dog
you can't get [ __ ] period but he needs
to upgrade the dogs I said to meet with
some but what he said to me the other
day which is hilarious that dogs like 14
years old
I think Hershey he already said he's
getting a new one I'm like Jesus not
even dead yet you're gonna go because
that's his crutch basically the way the
way what Scott usually I think I talked
about this on stage at my mom's memorial
but basically what he does is because
he's you know his he's uh in his I
wouldn't say late sixties but he he
basically like will go to chin chin you
don't I mean and they'll be like some
chicks there and have like a long leash
you only mean he kind of lets the dog on
the you know girls love little dog
master oh yeah he's the worst then he
soon as soon as he go he goes come back
here takes a picture with the girls and
the dog the only man and he says let me
get your phone number and then he text
is the picture of the phone number and
then a week later is eating their [ __ ]
as they're holding his dog and they're
sitting there holding a dog is like I
took a picture with this guy house
[ __ ] Gandhi eating my [ __ ] right now
you know so you know but everyone has
their thing to get [ __ ] yeah or get
good what's your thing my crooked penis
that's TMI yeah
yeah but wait you don't open with that
you're not at the club and you go what's
your thing I don't know is it being poly
sure yeah yeah yeah I think that's it
you know but then but you were so famous
at one time I think I think like after a
while like that kind of goes out the
window and then you're like stuck with
the person because it's kind of like you
know there's people that are famous that
you get to know that are not you know
this reminds me of reminds me of like
when you bring a famous comic up at the
Comedy Store somebody like you know like
a special famous guest and a and there
you go
introducing such a such a new car goes
oh but if they're not doing jokes after
like two minutes they're like okay funny
yeah it's a really that's is that that's
you're you are with the dating I think
that I think that's how it is in life I
think you know I think like you know
everyone you know likes people that are
famous or they known from their movies
or whatever it is and they have that
connection or like oh [ __ ] like this
guy's awesome and then they realize like
oh that guy's an [ __ ] or that guy's
really nice and and for me and
particularly like like you're starting
to know me but I don't want to say this
but cuz it sounds weird but I'm a really
nice person
yeah you are no I'm a nice person and I
think people are really surprised you
know I have an agent that books me
sometimes on the road and he's like god
I got to know you and you're not at all
what I thought and I think that has has
a lot to do with you know even like
Marilyn Manson yeah yeah it's like a
really nice guy you know I mean and it's
like that's the thing about personas
right and in you know in in you know
when you see people and you think a
certain way
and I'm not saying that everyone isn't
that way but there's a lot of people
that aren't how they really are right
like Gilbert Godfrey is a great example
of someone that on stage real life is so
holy sure and real life is so precious
and sweet and very you know it's such a
nice person so that's how it is you know
so yeah you know funny thing is like
when I first started doing comedy I took
a class with your sister mm-hmm UCLA
Extension Oh
yeah it was crazy yeah you know and then
I was that it was I suggest anybody this
trying to do comedy or even thinking
about it I suggest go to a comedy class
one time like whatever if it's like five
class whatever it is go to that string
of classes so you can get comfortable
with people that are like like-minded
with you and you're you're learning how
to do things and then you do your little
showcase show as a great first show and
then you're off and running hmm so I do
say yeah that was great for me because
the first time I ever performed was at
the Comedy Store
oh are ya for her graduation show Wow
you know but then I didn't realize at
the time how little respect the comics
there had further comics in a comedy
class in that particular class and then
towards the tail-end yes oh it was like
it was a weird yeah weird vibe yeah and
it took me like over ten years to
actually become a regular at The Comedy
Store after that yeah quitting and
coming back and all that yeah it's um I
think at the end of the day it's about
doing you know obviously as opposed to
whether you're in a class or you're just
doing in front of three people and you
know comedy is one of those things that
you know it chooses you you don't choose
it you know like I'm addicted to it you
know like it's in my blood that's a
product of your environment yeah and my
dad warning yeah my dad who's 92 years
old I just saw him in Vegas and you know
he's not doing stand-up anymore because
he's 92 and it's hard for him and and I
think if for instance I think if if
someone took a microphone away from us
we would die
you know like for my daddies I don't
want to say he's dying but he's not
doing great and a lot of it has to do
with the fact that they took that you
know they took a microphone away from
him because it's it's an addiction you
know it's something that we have to do
like I'm more comfortable on stage than
I am you know pretty much anywhere you
know I love just I feel more relaxed
especially in front of my audience so
like for instance when I go on tour I
have a particular audience that comes to
see me and I feel like warm yeah when I
walk out there's a lot of love that my
audiences have for me and it's pretty
pretty [ __ ] awesome you know
sometimes it makes me cry because
there's such a you know it's whatever
I've done in my career you know I've
somehow touched
emotionally you know from MTV days all
the way into the films all the way into
whatever it is that I've done and it
still did this day thirty years later
it's still just as strong and now
because of this social media podcast
it's even bigger
you don't mean a Netflix some of my
stuff's on Netflix and in you know and
it's just it's I'm very fortunate you
know I'm very fortunate yeah yeah I can
tell that you appreciate the life that
you have but I mean you grew up such a
you know it's such a weird way thrusted
on you from the very beginning daycare
was like yeah go over there and play
with Wow such as such as on stage I mean
mom my dad a lot of you know a lot of
people always talk about my mom they
don't talk about my dad he came to speak
at one of the classes that you're oh
great yeah that's and you know cuz
that's how it all started you know with
him and yeah you know and in you know he
opened for Elvis Elvis Presley opened
for Sinatra you know Sammy Davis jr. and
you know and all these guys so it was uh
don't tell Tom dreesen if someone else
open for Sinatra cuz yeah so but my dad
you know my dad is you know pretty
awesome yeah yeah he was a fun character
I always remember that and he was on
Sanford and Son oh wow yeah he was you
know he did a lot of a lot of stuff you
know how come he never wanted to do like
you never wanted to do like a sitcom or
you do want to do a sitcom or can you
see yourself being a TV dad now yeah
that would be cool I think so yeah you
write that right now hopefully after our
movie comes out you know I I feel like
there's something there yeah with the
movie we did guest house it was a guest
house yeah guest house thing was how
you're a house guest in a guest house
yes and I think maybe when that comes
out I think people will see me again
yeah I think this is like a resurgence
kind of because it's a starring role
it's an old-school Polly too
yeah it's a homage to old-school Poli
yeah but older old-school Poli yeah tell
us about it it's like a little bit you
know my care it's called guest house and
basically I play a squatter and a guest
house that won't leave which is a
premise that's kind of old but you'd
think someone would have done it and
it's never been done before
yeah which was so weird so it's kind of
like neighbors or you know one of those
films where I'm like in the back and
there's the Millennium Millenial couple
they you know they're buying this house
and this [ __ ] nut nut ball is in the
back of the house doing coke and getting
all [ __ ] up at first when I got the
script from Sam I was like this
character is doing coke I'm like I'm not
gonna [ __ ] do coke and then the soul
even more it got dragged into it I'm
like you know what this is hilarious
who does coke on camera no one the last
time they did that was in Scarface I
think this guy's doing lines and [ __ ]
China like negotiate his rent with the
guy in the front so he's kind of like
Spicoli meets you know meets Scarface
meets like what about Bob yeah you know
and likes fat girls and he likes chubby
girls yeah that's this thing so yeah I'm
I'm excited about it because there
aren't that many were like raunchy
comedies out anymore they're not any of
just fun comedies where people just go
and laugh and be like oh my god that was
so funny was rated R they're not even
doing that anymore yes and that's why I
think it'll do well is because it's
totally anti over the way it's the anti
PC film it's kind of like American Pie
or or you know or hangover where it's
like tits and ass and [ __ ] and drugs
and party and in over-the-top Butte
language and all that yeah and and
working with you was was awesome on it
because we got to just [ __ ] around yeah
that was fun time I gotta say you did
surprise me like not knowing you yeah
enough like you know just knowing just
gotta pass in the hallways but just
actually being there with you I was very
very pleasant experience thank you you
are missing you're misunderstood person
yeah now but what do you think about
like well how times are right now with
the PC culture with me to like do you
think that that lends itself to why
there aren't that many more raunchy
comedies right now you think you think
studios are scared to make well that's
you know I just think that's the
wait that's that's the way it is and I
think I think it's okay to get says I
don't I think it's okay to to uh to go
up to the line but not cross the line
and if you do cross the line you better
have a [ __ ] silly sense of humor
about it and I think that's with my
comedy as well as a lot of my comedies I
crossed the line but you know I'm not a
racist guy and I'm not really [ __ ] up
I'm just kind of having fun and it's
kind of like that whole thing is like
it's like in your system you can tell if
someone's not cool you know if you would
like to think I mean we'd like to think
that people have this kind of
sensibility that you're saying but it
seems to me that how often are we going
I can't believe these people don't know
that that's a joke yeah it's interesting
you know but but because even with your
own comedy like I don't are you trying
to push the envelope are you saying
things that are you just still right in
the pocket of like you know being this
Friday guy yeah I try to I try to go to
the edge edge and then I feel it onstage
as a performer when to kind of pull it
back you know and that's kind of like a
natural a natural kind of instinct
I just leaning right now it's weird like
you know they have to like take the cell
phones from people now because they're
recording their shows and it's like you
need you ever feel not I don't want to
say afraid but is there ever like like a
worry when yeah yeah absolutely good but
I had this I had this one joke where
like you know the n-word is such a bad
thing to say onstage and I always said
like you know if I said it like Al
Sharpton will get the video you know and
it'll be like I'll leave that guy alone
he's [ __ ] up enough he's got enough
problems we don't need to come after
this guy you know actually one of my
favorite things you've been would you
were doing is like about like not you're
gonna take over for Kevin Spacey yeah
Arius yeah is getting caught with the b2
and they're gonna have to hire you to
take over the roles oh yeah oh that was
the yeah that was a joke I did a while
ago about um pretty soon there's gonna
be no actors left except for except for
me I'm gonna thank Kevin Spacey for
touching those kids in London because of
you I could you know get on there I mean
it would be really funny yeah if I was
starring in house of cards and then he
would kill himself for sure he would
kill himself do you know he came to the
Comedy Store about a few months back oh
wow yeah I didn't know that till
somebody told me later it was like Kevin
Spacey was gonna be on and glasses is
hilarious can you even imagine if some
if one comic would have found out Wow
you know it means that the Comedy Store
yeah yeah oh my god yeah well that's
probably why he went there cuz he
thought he could be safe there yeah or
me or maybe he wanted to be like scene
and it gets out there especially at the
Comedy Store I think a lot of that stuff
has to do with how you are as a person
though - I mean like a Harvey Weinstein
in the Kevin and I don't I never I don't
know these guys I've never really maybe
I met Kevin once but I don't really know
how they were as people right so I think
that has a lot to do with it you know
what do you mean well not being cool not
being cool dude not being cool dude so
but yeah it's a weird um it's a weird
time you know I say that the thing about
the dinner the Internet is anyone could
put the [ __ ] out there that's the good
part and then the bad part is anyone
anybody [ __ ] out there so it's like it's
a different than it was when when I was
you know when I was you know starting
out it was basically sent your VHS tape
in and you fly to New York or LA and
that was it yeah you know an MTV was the
biggest thing in the world that's what
it was that's where all the kids were
and now I don't think kids really watch
MTV and they're sorta don't play music
on there no you know that's why you say
MTV The Learning Channel you don't learn
[ __ ] on there anymore even the weather
channel has reality shows I don't think
Comedy Central does comedy anymore you
know I mean like I don't know what this
is what it is what we're doing right now
direct-to-consumer what this is what it
is this is the business the Rogen's you
know the Ari's the bobbies you know
Tripoli's you know all these people on
your wall bill burr you know this is
this is the Avenue it's like you said
the other day everyone's got a Twitter
everyone's got an Instagram everyone's
got a podcast or something it was a
little little thing going alright yeah I
love it
I love it I'm really excited I'm 51
years old so I've been doing this for a
really long time so I'm kind of inspired
by things that you know or I get into
things that I either really like where
I'm if I'm not really into it I'm not
into
so what I did was I've had a podcast for
about a year it's called polishers
random rants and it's basically me
ranting on just observational stuff kind
of train of thought it's kind of where
my comedy came from back in the MTV day
which is just yeah but the crazy part
about it's not even this part it's the
fact that you yeah I put cameras you
just have random cameras in your house
yeah so it's basically like a porno
house without the porno part I haven't
bright side I might do pornos I was
telling no I was telling my producer
Tyler I'm like do it if I start banging
chicks on here you can still produce
he's like I don't know to have a wife I
mean I thought of it because I thought
it would be really interesting if I
really went on a date yeah from real
home and I brought her home but she
would have to know there's cameras oh of
course
yeah yeah of course so there's like I
have like 10 it's kind of like instead
of Big Brother it's big weasel it's kind
of like it's about a guy that lives
alone yeah and that's okay because if
you ever if you ever if you ever watch
TV shows it's always about a family you
know there's never about a guy if you
ever think of someone that lives alone
you think sadness I don't think oh he
lives alone you know he by himself so
it's about it and I'm okay living alone
am I gonna live alone forever probably
not yeah but that's what I really enjoy
about it I think there's a message to it
too because I get a lot of response from
people going [ __ ] I live alone - I cook
like that because if you live alone you
live alone when you make yourself food
you don't go or at least I don't go to
the [ __ ] dinner table and eat it yeah
that's [ __ ] sad yeah you just beat it
TV tray I did I have a table I have a
table in front of my couch
hilarious no no but no it's a it's an
end table right I'd like a regular light
but it it lifts up you know oh wow and
you just put it right put it right there
yeah it becomes a table again that's
exactly but you know it's because I do
now do you have married friends who are
always like on you about like come on
man it's time to settle down it's kind
of like you know um Bobby Lee hits me up
a lot I mean oh dear he yeah who is he
they give it a you know I've known
afraid I'm the one who discovered that
guy so like I've known him for four
years so he knows like there's a sadness
in me that I don't have kids
it's you know and at the end of the gig
I guess yeah yeah but he's just telling
me like you gotta have a kid you gotta
have a kid and I agree with him I want I
was thinking about going on eHarmony for
real because I have a friend of mine
that I didn't want I wouldn't say a
friend of mine I'd say someone that I
just met that met his wife on eHarmony
and I'm like why eHarmony and not a
bumble or a tinder like that because
when people go on bumble or tinder
they're just kind of [ __ ] around but
if you go to e harmony it's kind of like
I'm going to settle down expectation is
that you have to get your whole dossier
yeah yeah like the thing is is like if
you go on eHarmony that's like some
that's some like you're taking it more
serious okay you know so I'm thinking
yeah I'm thinking about going on
eHarmony for real because I want to have
a kid I do want to have a kid you know
but it's got to be with the right
situation
one thing you could just I think that on
your show right now you could just be
like you can actually do the bachelor
that's true
you put this out there in the universe
like I'm looking to yeah look at the
settle down yeah I was obviously yeah I
was also thinking of possibly talking on
one of my Instagram girlfriends like I
have girlfriends on Instagram not girls
that I'm sleeping with but just girls
that are friends that are girls that are
like my my pals or whatever I was
thinking about possibly getting there
there egg my sperm and putting in one of
my chubby fans in the Midwest and having
her live at my place least you gonna
have a fat girl have a hot girl like a
surrogate they'd be like a surrogate
because she doesn't want to get her
[ __ ] body [ __ ] up so that that yone
me so chubby girls like they're gonna be
like hey get your hot girls a hot girl
eggs and put it in put it in a chubby
girl to have little hot babies it's just
a thought that is just a thought that I
know there's a movie there I think there
is or a TV show called Pauly Shores
random ran at the four-plex which you
can see yet yeah but I really enjoy it
and I chase shoot two a week and I've
been doing there's probably like 15 of
them I started and it's cool I Filipino
neighbors I bring them on once in a
while and an eventually I'll start
bringing people on so it's like oh
people over it's a way to kind of
express my it's like it's pretty much
like me doing a set without jokes
you know all over much like one of your
sets yeah yeah yeah but with no material
that's kind of like just ranting on
anything you know so why are you okay
let's go back to this why why do you
think you you feel sad um well there's
been a lot of death in my life you know
a lot a lot already people yeah a lot of
death so you know and then my dad is
pretty sick right now you know and um so
I think that has a lot to do with it not
just with family members but um and then
I've been going through a lot of stuff
with my brothers which has been you know
hard yeah come on my sister died and my
mom died my best friend Gary died my dad
sick my other friend shot himself so
there's like a lot of [ __ ] that has been
going on so I just look at life a lot
different now then I then I did younger
you know it's like when your your
parents alive
yeah my mom's oh my it's just my mom but
speaking up my mom right now is like I
think dementia or something that's
kicking in right now and it's like it's
really it's really hard
ya know and I sit and I think about like
so when we're at our age and we're
thinking about like man should I have
kids because you're thinking about like
how we're here for our parents right now
yes and it's like well who's gonna be
here for us but it's also I think if you
talk to people that have had that are
older that have kids you know bill burr
[ __ ] Jamie Masada even you know it's
this like it is this like my point is is
there's a reason that they say that
they're so [ __ ] happy when they have
a kid that you even Sandy dant oh yeah
that's a [ __ ] kid he's young and he's
you know like even golem has you know
well you know what I'm saying yeah but
so I want to be able to leave this earth
one day like and be able to say like I
had a [ __ ] I had kid or a kid to
experience that you know whether it's
you know someone real that I'm settling
down with or whether it's a surrogate
whether it's some sort of you know
situation so well I think yeah yeah I
think that you know as we get older we
just become more vulnerable I think
that's what's happening with you
right now - is like you just yeah this
is just like a vulnerability of just
being like hey whatever you know this is
me now like I'm not trying to hide
anything yes this is this is who we are
let's might might you know when you get
older your interests kind of naturally
change yeah it's just slowly you know
what I mean like it's more important to
get a good night's sleep you know I mean
than it is to like go out and get [ __ ]
up you know what I mean or go to for me
I like to go to the gym I like to go to
the spa I like to eat good food you know
I like to watch TV I like to like so
it's a simple things and I talk I talk a
lot about you know just you know looking
at what you have not what you don't have
and I think that's important and that's
kind of a message you know you look at
life it's so [ __ ] nuts you watch TV
these kids that get killed in school
like they're sitting there [ __ ] at
school and all of a sudden some crazy
other kid comes in there goes the
person's life so my point is is every
and it sounds [ __ ] stupid and
whatever but my point is is the older
you get the more you realize you know
you really appreciate just the fact that
you woke up and you go do [ __ ] you know
I mean are you appreciating like life
now like not that you're doing the movie
you might start doing more things like
that the stay that that you're doing the
traveling you're doing are you more
content with that now than say you were
even at the height of it yeah yeah just
because you know it's a wrap in 30 40
years you know that's it you know you
make it to 80 you've won you only mean
I'm 51 so it's like I got 30 more years
if I'm lucky yeah you know or you know
my dad is sitting there his [ __ ] 92
and he's sitting there going I just
wanted I visit him a month ago ago two
months ago in Vegas I'm like dad you
want to go outside he's like for what
I've seen everything just leave me the
[ __ ] alone don't [ __ ] touch me you
know so uh I don't know it just comes
with time it's just weird your interests
start changing what do you what do you
want what do you want to do with this
next 30 years like what do you like what
do you want to accomplish in this stage
in your life um well my relationship
with my brother's you know I'd like that
to get you want to heal them yeah I'd
like that too you know somehow you know
so I move forward you know whoa why
can't you why can't it start to heal it
because it is I feel that you genuinely
want
to be a good thing and well there's a
lot of stuff that has gone on between me
and them in the back I don't want to
start talking about it yeah it's legal
[ __ ] you know what I mean and it is well
but tell me this do you have your own
resentments or are you holding on to
some [ __ ] that you might need to let go
to make this happen yeah I think so
yeah yeah I mean I'm not I'm not perfect
you know I've done some stuff and you
know they've done some stuff but I think
it's about you know that's the thing is
like I think about my mom a lot you know
about how she is you know and what would
she would she would be like you know
like like if I was like moping around
thinking about my mom my mom she would
be like what the [ __ ] you know move on
get over it [ __ ] Don is tired you
know my mom is always about moving into
the future and I think that's what I'm
enjoying my podcast because my podcasts
I don't go in at the Comedy Store [ __ ] I
don't go into any of my [ __ ] personal
life a little bit but it's always like
the future the future the future is you
living your life yeah living my life
right now but also commenting on just
random [ __ ] you know I mean it could be
anything about the 99-cent store you
know I'll just comment you know I was at
the 99-cent store and some guy was that
what are you doing at the 99-cent store
well it's funny bastard there's one
right at the bottom of my help okay
so I've gone in there but I just wrote a
joke about it but my point is is that
you know I think for all of us it's
important not to sit into the past is to
try to move into the future it's okay to
kind of nod at the past but if we keep
sitting in the past and talking about
all the [ __ ] in our lives that have
happened in the past
you just get depressed yeah you know and
that's for everyone you know I agree
yeah and it's like [ __ ] you want to just
move forward yeah I'd love yeah that
would be great yeah I'd love to see you
I'd love to see that happen yeah II have
them come to your house and beyond the
beyond the podcast yeah tell them
they're watching right now are they but
yeah we have a good thing going at the
Comedy Store you know my mom has really
created a beautiful a beautiful place
and I think there's a mutual respect
yeah with all the comics I think
everyone kind of you know we say the cop
the comedy star is the star not the
stars that played the Comedy Store right
you know there's that there's a mutual
respect in the history of that I think
she created that's embedded in all of us
when we go there myself included you
know
I don't run the light you know I don't
[ __ ] I don't play that [ __ ] you
know like on the owner and this is my
place and then that's never been my
style you know it's always about this
what's best for the store yeah yeah
right now too especially like there's a
lot of great stuff going on right now
that just like whatever this Renaissance
is happening right now this is like vibe
that's in a place and even in the city
too though because I can tell because if
you go to some of the other clubs I got
some of the same lineups
but it's my mom's feeling that my mom
created and it's the respect in the
rooms that she created and we're just my
brothers and I in the comics and the
staff are just trying to you know keep
that moving forward and I think that's
you know and that's kind of an all Maj
to her you know and yeah for sure yeah
and like you know you know there's if
there's a brotherly thing there you know
back like I'm like when I was younger it
was [ __ ] guns and drugs and all that
should people are [ __ ] waitresses on
the belly room stairs
oh the good old days yeah it was wild
dude that guy needs a documentary really
show he's got just weird I'm scared to
go he's a weirdo man I love him yeah
yeah he's a beautiful guy he's been
through a lot yeah it's been through a
lot I think you know what's so weird
about being at the Comedy Store is like
seeing all these people that we see all
the time it goes for years now you know
it's like you don't be there longer than
us you know still be there but it's like
I love that sort of like it's like a
weird extended family mmm but like
occasionally you get a chance to like go
even a little further because as much as
we know each other a lot of people
really don't know each other yeah it's
it's kind of like when you do movies you
know people always ask me about like oh
what's Brendan Fraser doing I'm like you
haven't seen him since we wrapped a
scene oh man yet amia what stephen
baldwin oh I see him sometimes people
think that people think that you know
comedians all hang out right Union and
we don't right no we don't like you know
what I mean
no they just want me nice effort Bryan
Callen and Chris D'Elia they always say
yeah yeah they seem to be like really
legit friends oh my god but that's it
what's great like I feel like I've made
some of my my best friends of my life
like Bobby
is one of my just one of my dearest
friends you know I mean even though he's
a little [ __ ] you know but why is
this [ __ ] he doesn't return texts no
he does know you were trying to text him
it's a nightmare
you know and I tell him I answered his
call one time he called me I was on
stage yeah in your hands and I answered
it because I was like oh just Bobby Lee
and I got he never calls so I got to get
this you know yeah and it actually was
about your movie he was like are you
doing a Bali movie I'm on stage and
you're on the thing you know but yeah so
he just doesn't answer it he's just a
weird he's got a lot of these guys have
like weird interpersonal issues I think
all comics to some degree we're all
comics are very kind of introverted very
much so I think we're very awkward and
we're very um you know nuts not so we're
socially awkward and and then like the
persona we create on stage is what we
want like that's what we're hiding
behind but like when it gets down to it
like this yeah it's like this is more
like how we would be anyway yeah like
you know I think people think comics are
sitting around just like cracking jokes
yeah god no we're like talking like deep
like to do you know yeah yeah unless
you're Bryan Callen Frank yeah it's the
only one but but also like back in my
dad my dad's days my dad used to belong
to the Friars Club which was like a big
Jewish kind of like you know you know it
was like you know as a club for for
older comics they used to do shtick
though that was you know I mean like
they would sit at you know it's kind of
like if we all went to canners you know
and just [ __ ] [ __ ] around but we
don't really do that no we were our
place so we started to go when I first
started coming up at the economy store
you know with crystally and all these
guys we would always go to a one-on-one
cafe mmm that's where we would that was
our that was our Cantor so now it's like
101 are swingers yeah we go to swingers
a lot yeah that's what you see a lot of
comic set you know Saturday night late
or Friday night late that's where we go
yeah I live in Silver Lake so I don't I
kind of like you know that's that's
another reason why I don't perform a lot
at the store yeah
like I kind of like being out there for
some reason there's something really
cool there's a peacefulness out there
pretentious energy now go to a coffee
shop without somebody writing the script
you know that's going everywhere
GuestHouse and you were in like you
thought you did the car no I just like
it cuz it's like the last silver like
Atwater Village Echo Park you know you
know Los Feliz I just think it's kind of
the last part of true Hollywood you know
well no if you think about if you think
about the buildings are being built on
Sunset Oh
true enough that's my point my point is
is the latter Amish girls gave me the
last building and it's gonna be a no my
point is it feels to me it feels like
there's a Tundra going over sunset and
taking out at the soul you know and the
you know the hippie vibe and the in the
party vibe and it's going out and all
these big huge high-rises are there and
I think like if you if you keep going
you get to like there's the Scientology
Center that area over there it just
becomes like you know Bill burr lives
out there you know Marc Maron lives out
there there's just something it's almost
like all these buildings out there are
so old they're in like in their 20s so
there's something I like about that I'm
not saying I'll be there forever but
just kind of where I'm at right now I
there's something I like there and plus
you have to understand that I was born
and raised on the Sunset Strip yeah I've
been at the Comedy Store my whole life
you've seen a lot of change on that on
that strip I mean imagine imagine the
House of Blues is gone isn't air and
they're putting up this like here
whatever the [ __ ] that is they're
putting oh is there in the 80s when my
mom I used to be a short-order cook at
the Comedy Store in Westwood and I and
then Alan Stevens and the comedian so
drop me drop me off at the store around
2:00 a.m. and my mom would come out
grabbing in her jag and we would drive
down sunset around 2:30 in the morning
and we'd go by we'd go by like the
whiskey on Sunset and Black Flag which
were still there yeah yeah whiskey and a
Roxy and all those little club yeah
Viper Room and it was just insane you
know I mean it was like a people were
throwing up on our windshield we drive
by no that's how it was and now it's
just like you know it's a big Instagram
video a naked chick selling pot you know
which is [ __ ] weird
do you ever think that the Comedy Store
do you think the commerce girl is gonna
be there forever I hope so
I mean I wouldn't you know I wouldn't
support knocking it down I mean
hopefully the comics you know if that
ever happens hopefully the comics would
support not knocking it down yeah you
know because for that I think I think it
should be a Hollywood landmark yeah it's
not no it's not oh but I think it should
be a Hollywood landmark similar to you
know the the Chinese wax me a Chinese
Theater and also the the the Capitol
building
yeah after us I mean after since 72 now
how long does it take to be a landmark I
don't know you know it's one of those
things I mean you know if I was being
like a greedy person I'd be like I could
also see like you know you sell the
property you haven't build whatever they
want to be able to top but the Comedy
Store is still there you know what I
mean like it was a different way but if
you do that then you're taking yeah you
if you do that then you're taking away
you know the feel of the building and I
don't think my mom would want that
course you know and plus the building
before the comedy store was Ciro's did
you know that right yeah it was an old
you know that's a natural uh Sammy Davis
and and that's where you know everyone
Marilyn Monroe everyone was there you
know so it's like that my mom took it
over at that time I think that I really
thought it was a national uh what do you
call it a landmark mm-hmm oh man what do
we got to do to make it a landmark have
the comics you know do a petition I
don't know is that well we should we
should actually really find out about
that we'll do it have to have the comics
to it you know we're the comics man well
they're also probably watching us I'm a
big interview for you the biggest guest
today I think it feels like it should be
you know but I don't know if there is
the whiskey and the Roxy Hollywood
landmark so I don't know I they know
they're knocking down the Viper Room
what yeah
I'm knocking down that whole bar you
know what the Viper Room was years ago
up to the hustler like the hustlers like
the next book I'm talking about like
some be liquor store there's a sushi bar
and then there's some there's like a
trinket place there you know that hole
yes yes yes you know that whole thing
but you notice they knock down or they
they built a big a big parking thing and
they kept Cabo Wabo hilarious that's
hilarious
you see that that's funny
well you know what you're doing a little
mole on the side of this big [ __ ] but
not that hug was well they probably
that's what happened oh I'm sure but it
but like you know right next to pink dot
they're tearing all that down mm-hmm you
know so that's gonna be like a very
should fear live there that's gonna be
another monstrosity yeah but they're
gonna put right here probably gonna be
it's probably gonna be good for this
store yeah all that cuz I cross I think
it's gonna be a hotel or something
across the street so that's just gonna
increase business but I think I think
the comments are the fact that it's
doing so well I think is another reason
why you just want to leave it alone yeah
you know if it was if it was dead and
there was nothing going on there then
there would be that conversation right
right right I think the fact that the
comics of all they're all coming out and
doing it so yeah well that's good man
I mean I do appreciate that so like I
know with the movie that we did you
wrote a lot of it yeah now is this gonna
be a thing that you're gonna be doing
are you gonna be writing more movies are
you writing movies right now like what
do you do I have I have a project well I
have a couple documentaries in the can
you know really document did you direct
are you just yes
I didn't both I put them together there
was a there was a documentary that I did
called stands alone which was on
Showtime a couple years ago and then I
kept filming and I have a six-part
series based off of that and that was
all the stuff kind of leading up to my
mom's passing oh wow and that was pretty
heavy so I have that that's that's in
the can and that's already cut and then
I also have a historical documentary of
my life that I did you know what I call
just Paulie maybe I don't know but I did
that and there should be called are you
sure or maybe a car if in with the weeds
oh my god so I have that and then I have
another script called captured which is
a comedy film which I like the guys that
did our movie to do and that's a it's a
movie about with me and Bobby Lee it's
where I captured him I put him in a cage
in my backyard and it's kind of like a
movie about for me what's a movie about
friendship why would you okay so you use
on my character
character my lead character Skippy he
can't keep a friend because everyone has
life either leaves him or he wants them
out so the only way he could keep her
friend is if he doesn't puts him in a
cage but he doesn't capture anyone he
catches Bobby his character because he
wants to capture someone whose life is
more [ __ ] up than you know oh wow this
sounds dark yeah so when he captures
almost a boss so I see him yeah I see
him in a parking that I go and I hit him
and he wakes up and he's in this cage
but he's got us with Nintendo he's got
all this stuff and he's yelling at me
and him like he's like get me out of
here I'm like dude you're good don't
worry about it and then you know so
frightening but we want you to play the
cop in it yeah so what are you watching
right now so do you watch documentaries
like what keeps you entertained what
shows are you watching what not the Amy
Schumer Netflix special no miss the
views expressed by Polly sure are not -
hey that both people up what are you
talking about literally that's another
reason why half the kids don't get a
special wait for the guy why is this
pregnant to come out with a special yeah
[Laughter]
poster and what are you watching I you
know I love guilty pleasures I love
watching sports I'm obsessed with
basketball Oh what do you think about
the NBA right now this [ __ ] dude from
Milwaukee he's a [ __ ] hand yeah yeah
he's not onto the comp oh I can't
pronounce his name it is [ __ ] he's an
honest level down oh that's the next
Kevin Kevin Durant right there he's
[ __ ] they can't win the championship
dude I think so I think it's gonna be
[ __ ] them and gold and see if you
sing I mean Houston I mean it's great I
love this it's like I mean I don't know
if it's Jews love basketball but Jews
[ __ ] love basketball I've always
loved basketball ever since I was a kid
you think what you think have some what
why would it have anything to do with
being a Jew I don't know what it is you
know I don't know what it is it's just
one of the sports that Jews love if you
look at the side of the Lakers so that
you know they go into the Clipper games
you got Billy Crystal yeah yeah
just love it I don't know maybe because
it's fast and Jews are like like to move
around or something I don't know it is
but I love basketball so I you know I
love you know the LeBron things pretty
[ __ ] nuts what like what's gonna
happen that was he was never eaten fit
right here personally this would to play
out while he don't eat shoulda came to
the Clippers was what he should have
done correct should've gone to Clippers
right city wrong team yeah we they'd
stay people still play be playing right
now correct you know everything he's
like you know can I just like change the
job I heard one of those I love watching
those debate shows I watched speak for
yourself
first take watch although even a Smith
yeah yeah I was first take in the
morning I tape them so I can watch him
whenever oh you know but the they were
talking about like will LeBron asked for
a trade mmm cuz he was blindsided by the
Magic Johnson thing well he's just
saying that he was like using that as an
excuse well who cares like I don't like
the Lakers yeah so if he comes to the
Clippers I'll be happy but for now I'm
like I'm glad they're doing bad yeah but
I'm just tired of like two teams I'm
trying to go the state because I feel
like all this talk about Kevin Durant
leaving it's like then that doesn't seem
like a team I want to support you know
what I mean they're he's just like a
hired gun and he's gonna leave so get
him out of here yeah and the same thing
with Boston I'm glad Boston is about to
lose cuz same thing Kyrie Irving yeah
all year they're talking about carryover
is not gonna stay Kevin Durant is not
gonna stay so I don't want to see those
teams I want to see like Denver yeah
Denver's great they all these stars are
under five there are so good the main
dude was this they in the big white
another one kitch yeah he's [ __ ] with
this passes yeah he's like seven-foot
look it's got 27 like assists in the
last two games I'm like that like if
gonna stay things are just gonna zip
past them right that would be the great
upset that would be I think Houston's
gonna be going to say that I would like
them to be going to stay but I just
don't think it's gonna happen
yeah cuz cuz when they get back to
Oakland it's like well I mean they could
beat them I just want to see what they
do in a close game on the road you know
I just haven't seen that and I haven't
seen Houston step up you know
especially James Harden he always he
chokes along and then they look we had
Chris Paul with the Clippers and he his
move is to get hurt mmm that's his move
is his go-to yeah you don't I mean so
we'll see if it survives that but but
who you got for the championship
man well I would love I would love it to
be I would love it to be like obviously
Denver and Milwaukee would be awesome
now no one would watch but as a
basketball fan that would be a great
matchup but I don't think that's gonna I
could be the one that's gonna move the
ratings yeah that's not gonna move the
needle yeah you know but okay so you
watch sport's yeah I like basketball you
watch basketball not I like football -
of all season but yeah what's shown in
watch it and then I like watching our
president I like watching you know
Donald Trump [ __ ] cuz I'm in shock you
know think it's a dill shock it does
nothing shocked really I mean no not now
it's kind of like an old joke yeah
it's kind of like it's kind of like an
old joke but I just love the fact that
he gets everyone so pissed off so I
think it's hilarious you know and the
thing that's [ __ ] up is that he might
win again oh I would put money that he
don't win again do you think Joe Biden
could beat him no the thing is is like
the piers the problem
the Liberals you know and I find myself
to be a self-hating liberal because I
just don't like what the party's doing
but I feel like people in the liberal
side they love to hate Trump more than
they like any candidate on the
Democratic Party right so they're just
it's just more attention to him all the
time look even we're talking about him
right now right yeah one Democrat I
think the only person that can and I'm
not just saying that to be funny and
this is one of my jokes but it's a real
true story I think that the only person
that could beat Donald Trump is the rock
for real like if because he's bigger
he's more famous he looks better Trump
supporters like the rock because he's
like a wrestler yeah you know Bill Maher
I think he said Oprah so no it's not I'm
just saying but it's not out of the
realm of possibility
now the Trump is one that someone that
just lies completely unqualified in
politics
actually become present I think that's
the only hope is the rock he's not gonna
do it that he's not gonna do it but I
think he would win
yeah but the moment the rock becomes
like runs for office all of a sudden
they're gonna dig he's gonna be
scrutinized they're gonna be like oh
look how he hit that guy with your chair
oh yeah sure all that stuff will be come
within the redneck just the rock but
then the redneck fans will be like man
[ __ ] it he's awesome that's cool dude
he's a rock man he was in the TV Barry
maybe I think that's my only sir or you
know everyone's got to get behind Biden
or [ __ ] Bernie which I don't see
happen just pick one
that's all I'm saying is we need to pick
they need to tell us hey we're gonna go
with this guy then we all go okay yeah
listen I had the same [ __ ] to happen
before you know cuz right now it's not
looking good I think Barney's got to go
man he's gotta go he's got to go because
he already lost to somebody that lost
okay he got outplayed
by somebody they got got outplayed by
the winner so I don't think he's got it
in him to do but let's move on let's get
some new blood in there man right I
don't know what to say I mean right now
there's the Biden's the only one seems
to be but his whole tactic about just
all he does is he just he's just
attacking Trump every day now he's
calling him Oh what did he call him a
baby or something like he just he's just
always like he's like dude he's trying
to Trump Trump yeah you know so they
like trumping each other and then what
else do i watch I think SportsCenter and
I watched politics and then what others
stepped out someplace you know Game of
Thrones no no no Vampire Diaries no you
don't you don't have any guilty pleasure
shows man I just believe the gram
stories that's pretty entertaining look
looking for mrs. Shore just watching
people's instagrams that night are
pretty funny um I'm trying to think what
I seen on I saw some [ __ ] crazy
documentary sandy told me to see about
some guy that I forgot his [ __ ] that
he was just I liked watching stuff that
people tell me to watch oh you know like
hey you got to see this so you got to
see that but I forgot the name of the
doc I know yeah well I can't believe
you're not like you've been in the
entertainment business so long yeah is
it because you just don't want to you
just want to be out of it or like like
what like you're trying to write movies
you gotta watch what's going on out I
already know how to write movies no tell
me tell me some stuff and I'll tell you
give me some stuff Game of Thrones I
don't watch but I want to watch you
wanna watch I wanna watch Breaking Bad
when it was God keep going
what's the one on I'm dying up here did
you watch him nine everywhere said now
you [ __ ] right every time I
would see you it'd be like we're gonna
kill you that's you sorry that was weird
that was a weird thing for me yeah yeah
but you know what there's like people I
just think that they used the name of
the book just because they had a name
but the show was about Jim it was about
his stories yeah you know he lived in a
closet when he first came to LA you know
he he had a fight in a parking lot and
he you know he uses the stories that he
knew and that's what he when he
remembered that's what the show was
about cuz it's very fascinating he took
us all to dinner mmm first season and
he's like starts telling stories and it
was just like really like he captivating
to hear his point of view about that era
yeah he just wanted to show it but the
[ __ ] should have been on the
show yeah he should have been like a
come and be an agent be something like
gonna use your fame to help that goddamn
show today on the air you don't I mean
yeah it was you know you didn't even
watch it at all I saw a little bit of it
but it's hard it was hard for me to see
my mom portrayed that way yeah but but
but again the comedy scene this is what
people don't understand the Comedy Store
existed in our show this wasn't the
Comedy Store like in our show we made
reference to the comedies yeah I know I
know there wasn't obviously there wasn't
a lot of stuff that were it was real
about the Comedy Store in it yeah but I
know but that's what I'm say cuz we it
wasn't the Comedy Store
it was Goldie's I understand you know it
was just still it was still based on for
a club in the seventies run by a female
and that was close enough yeah yeah but
she wasn't but she was very much like
not trying to be that she wasn't no she
was very do miss Aleeah was always like
I'm not making sure I'm this person hey
you know so but I understand I get it
yeah so but I don't know that's like it
was like mixed reviews you know it's
like I know a lot of comics that really
enjoyed watching it and then there's
something like just the old like
Doug Stanhope was always talking [ __ ] he
didn't like it yeah and I heard Leno on
Maron he didn't like it yeah
so it was mixed bill burr loves it yeah
I I'd have to watch it more to like see
like if I really you know maybe when I
get older I'll bail look at it just look
at it yeah where can I see it on Hulu
Sonos you have money you get Showtime is
still on Showtime okay yeah you know
let's see I've watched uh there's a good
show on you like party a prime like what
do you have an answer by Mia the prime
prime Netflix yeah yeah you got all the
good stuff yeah you're not even watching
the stuff tell me what to watch I like
this show Hannah show Hannah was good
that's on prime it's based off the movie
but they made it into a show but this
little female assassin like she's like
you know she grew up with her dad in the
jungle or whatever you know what kind of
movies I like because I think that's the
problem I like movies like moonlight Oh
what Academy Award film moonlight so you
like pretentious movies I like movies
with good stories and good directors and
some good actors
well that's movies somebody watch TV
sometimes you watch TV just to escape
man you know like you don't always have
to learn [ __ ] or appreciate the lighting
in a movie to enjoy it no I like good
stories you know so that's why I like to
moonlight so if you can tell me there's
a good story to watch oh my god okay
Hannah Hannah what else tin star that's
another good one Tim Roth is in that one
and you're a star ten start us on prime
also okay text them to me
you know well that's it I don't have you
on again and we're gonna talk about
these shows so sandy look people text me
I'll watch this watch that and then I'll
start watching and although yeah this is
cool yeah no I want to see it yeah I
just don't know what to say you know
watch network television at all you've
never seen like Grey's Anatomy or or or
nothing like that not for me how to get
away with murder
dances with the stars American Idol me
not family not even Last Comic Standing
did you like watching CNN
[ __ ] on Trump Oh
honey you're an old man now you are you
probably watch jeopardy no no no I can't
believe you're not watching like any
comedies at all no comedies it's hard
for me to watch comedies why is that
well I've been around tough critic yeah
I've been around it my whole life so
even at the store it's hard for me to
watch the comics really really why is
that cool cuz I watched you know you
know Sam Kinison and Richard Pryor and
Robin Williams on that stage Eddie
Murphy is a different vibe yeah you know
time what he needed they needed an act
no but I'm not saying that the comics
aren't funny now I think there's a lot
of really really I mean you're hilarious
there's a lot of really funny comics but
just the energy and in the way that it
was back then
is different now even though there's the
same amount of butts in the seats right
like when how is it different tell me
what describe to me the direction Pryor
was like Jesus Christ okay when he
walked on stage it was like you know I
mean it was like seeing someone like
that or George Carlin when he walked on
stage it was like now is it because is
it because they were so famous at the
time cuz they were so funny okay it's so
funny I mean like an even Eddie Murphy
when he would come in and you know he
would roll in and he would go onstage he
was like back in the the raw days when
he did raw like he was performing at the
store at that time and it was like it
was a different it was insane well at
that well see that's an example of
somebody's I know super funny but I'm
saying at the time was larger than life
yeah but super funny yeah every funny as
[ __ ] dude yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] like I mean
when he was on stage and even when I
watched George Carlin towards you know
before he passed just like he would go
at the store and you just like he was
like a doctor on stage he would sit in
the back in the end of his bad there and
he was just like go into this for like
an hour and a half two hours and just
like Jesus Christ Wow so it was just so
that's what I'm saying even music for is
the same for me it's like I like music
now but I'll listen to like a Led
Zeppelin or I'll listen to the stones or
I'll listen to The Beatles or your
object or even like Smashing Pumpkins
you know or Alice in Chains or these
bands
that that you know that to me you know
the Allman Brothers you know the things
like that that I listen to I just think
you know and the music's good now I you
know I hear some stuff now but it's not
I get you like well you were an old soul
from jump you had to be right yeah cuz
even as a little kid you couldn't be a
little kid yeah yeah so but you don't
think that it rivals at all like you
like when Chris Rock comes in and
Chappelle comes in and bit when bill
burr and even Louie before he like fell
from grace it wasn't you don't feel you
don't feel that same kind of thing when
those people are on stage Chapelle a
little you know Chapelle a little rock
appelles great I mean I think he's great
I like both his specials you know what
do you think about all the specials I
think there's too many specials or are
they not special anymore to you or do
you watch them you watch I try to watch
them you know I try to give people the
benefit of the doubt
you know I know I just have to be like
you're oftentimes disappointed well I
just I don't know you know it's I'm a
hard critic for comedy I like guys like
I like I said I like you I like Bobby I
like Bill burr I like you know I like
Phillippe you know you know that's it
hey there's no more pictures
no I'm a different critic you know I'm a
different I'm a different critic also
like musically are you hi Eric no I
don't think I am okay I don't think I am
no you're harsh picky critic yeah well
it's like the thing is it's like I'll
see I'll see and I don't want to name
the specific comics but I'll see them on
stage at the store and they'll be doing
well and the audience's is laughing and
I'm watching you know and they're there
they're doing well and and then I'll be
like you know like these these this
audience they don't this is what they I
don't say this is what they think but
this is what it is right now and this is
what they're this is they're drinking
the punch this is this is what it is and
and then I'm like thinking like 20 30
years ago is what
you know Andrew Dice Clay when he first
Robin Williams I'm like I wish this
generation could have seen that you know
and maybe they have or maybe they will
you know maybe they'll get more even
Rodney Dangerfield [ __ ] dude
I mean [ __ ] this guy was hilarious I
mean just like not you know do you feel
at all that this attitude is just old or
is it like a little bit of that and a
little bit of like the the people of old
were just better at it or is it I think
it's what you just said I think it's
both I think part of it is I'm older and
part of it is that they were just better
that's just that's my opinion the kids
might say Oh blah bah bahs awesome right
you know maybe I'm not a touch I don't
know you know maybe that's that's it but
I mean that comes with age though I feel
like I just feel like once you hit 40
you just become out of touch and not
cool anymore you're not like you know
and the struggle to still be cool is the
real is the real it's like yeah it's
like when you go to a club you know you
know I used to be the guy you know
around the the you know around the
bottle and now I'm the guy behind
looking at the people I put the bottle
yeah I mean I'm like [ __ ] you think I go
and it's so loud in here it's it's in
it's one of those things that it just
naturally happens it's not like I woke
up one day and you know I mean right
yeah it's just slowly you slowly start
to your interest always start to change
you may have one thing but sometimes you
wake up in them like it it can't happen
suddenly hmm when you're just at a club
you know and then someone says like
excuse me sir or or you know you know or
like you know you get that like are you
like you're security or something or are
you the manager then you go oh I'm not
supposed to be here yeah and this is
this is not funny so that's why I talk
about bringing it back to having a kid
you know I think that I think that would
be something that would be new and fresh
for me you know it's like I've done so
much and I've seen so much and I've been
through so much that the one thing that
I haven't been through is having a
family or a child and I think that would
be really interesting and be fresh for
me and I think would bring you know this
this kind of unconditional joy in my
life
I don't have well I think that you're
gonna get there man yeah I think I think
that this version of yourself right now
you got to put that out there more what
about these shoes these shoes won't get
kids though
yeah let's see now and then you just
lost everybody it was a sweet moment we
was about to go into they'll put the
landing gear out for a girls to be oh
and then he pulled the slipper off okay
so you're killing me um no we're gonna
get you on eHarmony and I think that the
hilarious the blast you should do is
like on your show you should go fill out
your ivar money profile okay and then
just like start doing it why not so I
think that I hear genuinely in your
voice that this is something that you
want to do and you just have to like you
just have to do it man yeah yeah yeah
you know what woody what are you
actually gonna do my friend Eric's here
he's filling out he's filling an
eHarmony profile for himself right he's
been through a lot of [ __ ] to you know
he's been going through stuff with girls
too and it's it's just hard it's hard
you know you're single right
Wow you've recently yeah yeah but you
know what I'm saying it's I know I get
it it's like you know I don't know I
think that I don't know I think if you
had a bad situation you you you know
you're yeah yeah we're to a bad breakup
yeah if you don't want to talk about it
no I would like to but it's it's too
fresh and I don't think oh no but you
you still used to still painful no I
just don't think that that person would
want their stuff out there and I got a
respect you know yeah you right you
right
she was a [ __ ] no but I'm saying we get
like now where this from saying look how
vulnerable you are about this I could
tell that I could tell this about you
right now this fam you think is really
important to you this last girl hurt you
greatly yeah you're still dealing with
that you know you know and I could tell
this thing with your family is something
that you really want to get resolved and
fixed and I live the rest of your life
knowing that I fixed this with my with
my family I could tell that these are
things that you really want to do and I
I'm just I just hope you achieve those
things I want you to yeah you know I
feel like you're my psychiatrist but I'm
just
I'm just no I'm just like you know you I
know why I get it completely now why'd
these crowds that are coming to see you
all the time I get it because you are
you are a very pleasant person but
you're just like you know vulnerable you
know it's like people can feel things
from you mm-hmm and so you have to just
like clean out your life of all that
[ __ ] you know and they've fixed it
things you could fix and then carry on
yeah so you're 92 in Vegas you know that
until then you know what I mean mmm how
come there's not a Comedy Store in Vegas
by the way I don't know there I mean
there's so there's so many comedy clubs
out there now didn't Jimmy Kimmel just
oh yeah Jimmy Kimmel just open one you
know but there's enough there's enough
people out there for I don't know I mean
you gotta talk to the family about that
yeah I don't understand because then it
would just book the comics you know yeah
they gotta yeah we not Caroline's but
the seller just opened up one in in
Vegas and I'm like mm-hmm you can't just
you can't have the seller out in Vegas
and not have economies maybe we need to
open one in Jersey right since they care
or no Atlantic City yeah exactly
all right where we at oh look at that
see that's how we do it that's awesome
well anyways this is I guess I'm glad
you came on I hope we do do more
projects together it really was fun yeah
it was fun you know
yeah guest house to like you know yeah
yeah it'll be on a boat though you know
no I I really enjoyed having you in the
film yeah it's great when we went could
we it's coming out it'll probably cuz
gonna get a theatrical release yeah yeah
for sure it's go we're not going to get
slicks y'all yeah we go right to
theaters yeah
it'll be out I think at the end at the
end of this year early next year I'm in
touch with Sam director on it and we're
just kind of like you know they're doing
the Edit so that's all yeah that's the
old edit so we'll have like a screaming
and all that kind of yeah be great but
um but you know I'm excited about I'm
really excited about my show too right
yeah random rants podcast which is all
videos now which is kind of like Big
Brother but with one person you can find
that on YouTube
website I'm having all in the
description yes I know about all these
things so you have Polly's ransom what's
it called again Polly shows random manse
Pauly Shores random rants random rants
it's me just going crazy in my apartment
just yeah about whatever I just got that
you can see him there and and then you
can also of course on your website right
you can get all the tour dates no so
today it's my Instagram all the stuff
you have I have whatever you have I have
we all have the same [ __ ] you know and
and watch my Eric Griffin's random rants
I have
I'm putting cameras up yeah yeah but
thanks for having me just in the
bathrooms but now I appreciate you
coming on you are a joy to be around
and anyways that's been another episode
of riffing with Griffin tune in next
week I don't know how I'm gonna have yet
but we'll see if they could top this one
and once again thanks to mr. Pauly Shore
for coming on the show beautiful man we
gonna get him a relationship he's gonna
fix all his issues he's gonna come back
I'm gonna get to talk about it I'll have
like a baby carriage over here be like
you got somebody pregnant
but anyways is there a Griffin signing
off
see you next
[Music]
[Music]